yeah hi I'm Lily Jones I'm with everyone
on the table but tick Neil Young coming
from Hackney I think that it would be
amazing thing for the world leaders to
go to it not not only hackneyed but
somewhere that is less fortunate and
really see the lives of people and what
they're going through you know I've been
brought up in place by clapping hotkey
where a lot of use right now are dying
babies children I can children it's
ridiculous and I think they make 60 that
need to be there to be able to see and
see what they're going for it and the
reasons why they're doing it and not put
that support into it they need to know I
need to understand why why they doing
this and I think that's the only way
they'd really be able to gain that
knowledge of spread go and experience it
for themselves but the monitor stop the
violence exactly but not just in Hackney
but everywhere in the world that is
affected by that sort of problem